Washington journal continues and as we
continue on this Friday morning more on
campaign 2010 with a special focus on
women and the election year let me
introduce you to our two guests who are
both pollsters for their respective
parties Kellyanne Conway Republican
pollster polling company is her firm
Margie Romero is a Democratic pollster
and her firm momentum DC thanks to both
of you for being here this morning thank
you since you're both pollsters I'm
gonna go to a third-party polling source
for my first question this morning
yesterday in the Wall Street Journal
they did a guy's and Paul's but it was
really also than showing about women
party preference in 2006 women Democrats
Republican 51 to 36 to 2010 that number
has has moved but only slightly 52 39 by
contrast men 53 to 39 back in 206 41 to
50 in 2010 for Democrats to Republicans
so big movement there what do you think
if I could ask both of you and let's
start with Mark O'Meara what's happening
to women in this campaign cycle thinking
about candidates well III think that
you're gonna continue to see a gender
gap where women are going to prefer
Democratic candidates Democratic Party
over men and that's something that has
been happening for decades and since
we've been looking at exit polls in the
early 80s and I think that's going to
continue to be true because of what
we're seeing in the in the national
debate and the party that's consistently
at least in my view and clearly a more
women's view really sticking up for
women's issues more than the other side
om Conway thank you this is really the
year in 2010 when you're starting to see
a pulling away by women from these
traditional quote women's issues this
whole idea that the way to reach out to
women is to lead with abortion and then
have a footnote about education or
health care has really evolved this
cycle into economic issues this whole
basket of issues for women for 28
straight months now has been jobs in the
economy is their number one issues I
believe Susan and Margie that the
average female voter now is more
financially sophisticated
than she was in past elections and she
is saying the economy is most important
to her this is this is the first step I
think in what you'll see as a real
transformative process for many women
who
are not enraged as many people hate to
say but engaged in the political process
a poll we recently recently really
showed that women are saying they're
having more political conversations this
year they're using the internet more as
a tool to try to bring them up to speed
on the issues and the candidates of the
day and I think seeing is the first step
toward believing for female voters and
this year they're seeing many more
female candidates what are your numbers
saying about how important the economy
is to others well actually I agree very
much with Kellyanne I mean it is to
think that women care more about
abortion as a woman's issue I agree I
think both sides sometimes can put that
in the basket of women's issues when
women just like men young people just
like older people say the economy is the
number one issue and the the economy is
the number one issue we're in a national
economic downturn so so I see that as as
very much something that's important to
women and in much the same way that
Kelly hands it well when you drill down
into your polling results when you ask
about which party can better address
economic issues even if they're
generally supportive of the Democrats
how do the Democratic candidates fare
with women I think Democratic candidates
fare very well and I think the it's not
just the economy but how do you talk
about the economy you know for example
in a way that is specific to women's
issues like lilly Ledbetter
making a gender pay equity a priority is
something that has a very clear party
difference and it's something that men
and women frankly support and it's a
good example showing how the Democrats
are on the side of women another example
when you talk about health care rather
than simply talking about health care
broadly but about what it means for
women in terms of mandatory maternity
coverage as opposed to Republicans like
Senator Kyl sneering about so I don't
need maternity care so I think those are
some examples of of how you can talk
about these bigger issues in a way that
reaches out to women in question when
you drill down how do all women rape the
two parties on economic issues well
women tend to prefer slightly the
Democratic party on the economy but it's
a much smaller gap than they prefer the
generic Democrat in the Congressional
ballot so it tells you again that they
are looking at this election through an
economic lens and there the Republican
Party has really gained ground
particularly over 2006 when there was
just a bit
of trust with respect to the Democratic
and Republican parties visa vie women on
the economy
you know we released a poll last week
that showed slim majorities but
majorities nonetheless of women across
this country believe that the stimulus
tarp the balance of the auto industry
and of course a health care reform have
been failing more more have been
failures and successes and I think
that's a very important insight because
if the bailouts and the initial spending
for many women where the tip of the
iceberg
then health care is really the tipping
point who would have thought that a
majority of women now going into these
elections would say quote I'm against
health care reform they mean that
they're against what passed trillion
dollar price tag women control two out
of every three health care dollars spent
in this country they are the chief
health care officers of their households
and they overpopulate the health care
industry they are ninety five percent of
of nurses they are ninety eight percent
of home health care aides they're forty
nine percent a pharmacist they're about
a third of doctors now and even higher
in medical school students and yet they
rejected this health care plan they
heard we're going to invite thirty
million new people to the rolls and not
a single new doctor we're gonna have an
individual I think that dumped the big
story here is that President Obama who
beat two women to become president who
beat Hillary Clinton in the primary and
who beat the ticket that Sarah Palin was
on in the general is now way down among
women he won women by eleven points
which was a remarkable margin two short
years ago and his approval ratings have
now dipped well under fifty percent
among women well before you absolutely I
want to put that number on the screen
this is from American University ABC
News about women voting in the last
election fifty three percent of those
who voted of the approximately 131
million were were women and of those
fifty six percent voted for Senator
Obama compared to 43 percent for Senator
McCain what is the report card when
you're asking specifically women about
how the president is doing right now his
term well we did some focus groups with
Walmart moms and these are moms of
children under 18 living at home and we
went to three cities where there were
targeted Senate races and we found it's
not inconsistent to say
I think the president could be doing a
better job at the economy but not
blaming him or this heat that you
sometimes hear in the news about the
people who feel these very extreme views
and and we found that women don't feel
that way they could say look the economy
is not improving fast enough for me
because I'm still struggling but no one
would have been able to do to be able to
recover this quickly from what was
happening in the Bush administration at
the end of 2008 and and what we feel
sorry for him we had a lot of women say
I feel sorry for him this is very
difficult and McCain wouldn't have done
a better job and it was just so bad and
but it's not good enough yet for me and
I think that's what a lot of women here
and they have a lot more nuance than
sometimes we give them credit for than
our media can sometimes seem to suggest
well we're talking about women and a
campaign 2010 and we'd like to give you
the phone numbers and our other
addresses so you can call or comment on
our topics for the phone lines
Republicans to 0 to 737 triple zero one
Democrats to zero to seven three seven
triple zero two and our line for
independence is 6 to 8 0 to 0-5 with
that to zero to area code you can also
reach us on Twitter at c-span WJ and we
have an email address and you can send
your comments by email if you'd like
we'll put that on the bottom of the
screen before we get to calls I want to
move from women voters to women
candidates this is a set of statistics
from Rutgers University Center for
American women in politics looking at
the Senate races a record year 36 women
filed for US Senate 22 women lost their
primaries or eliminated at nominating
conventions in the House races also a
record year 262 women 334 DS 128 ARS
filed for US House previous record was
set in 1992 and right now there are 123
women lost in the primaries there are 69
incumbents rerunning running for
re-election 12 on open seats and 57
running as challengers overall demand
and women today in 2010 respond
differently to female candidates well I
think it depends on case-by-case and you
know I want to start off by saying I
think the number of Republican women can
is a great thing as somebody who works
with Democrats only I still like to see
Republican Women candidates and they can
be very accomplished executives and they
could be perennial candidates without a
whole lot of knowledge of the basic
facts they can have the whole range and
I think all that is progress for women
candidates just like male candidates
come in all shapes and sizes so so I
think that that's a good thing and I do
but I do think that women candidates of
both parties do sometimes have to go
through some personal attacks that maybe
men don't have to or it just seems a
little bit there's a little bit more of
a cringe moment that we've seen with a
lot of candidates on both sides
Democratic women candidates Republican
women candidates and I think we still
have some struggle and some obstacles in
that regard miss Conway agreed we all
came out of 2008 I think particularly
female strategists who do this feeling a
little icky for the way that senator
Clinton and governor Palin were treated
often by female journalists me I had and
female activists but fast forward to
2010 and you see a record number of
women running so the depressing effect
that so many people feared on women
wanting to run for higher office really
was not seen there's such an
inordinately our dues and Haute Couture
when it comes to female candidates where
are these were these stories Susan and
Margie about them the pond she beer
bellies and the bad comb-over is in
Congress and there are plenty you never
really read those and I just remember
when governor Palin was nominated I
received many calls from journalists and
the narrative quickly became later that
same day oh my god she has five children
including a brand-new baby who's a
special needs baby I'm really worried
about the children I'm thinking I've
read your columns you don't even seem to
like children now you're worried about
her children but I think that what the
response to that really should not be i
rolling in frustration so much as an
explanation that motherhood is a choice
and it's one it's it's on your biography
like anything else and I learned to say
well look you know Sarah Palin's got
plenty of time I guess to be the vice
president United States because she
doesn't have a boyfriend and she doesn't
play golf so right there she's got 20
extra hours a week that a lot of these
guys
don't have but in terms of the record
number of women running it really has I
think added a great deal to the debate
because you see these women out there
not just talking about education health
care abortion there they're out there
talking about the economy and on the
Republican side you have people like
nikki Haley and South Carolina's first
generation Indian immigrant who's
helping run her family's success story
their business you've got Mary Fallon in
Oklahoma now using her motherhood as an
asset in that race through some of her
ads women are usually seen as the
outsiders and that's a tremendous
strength for women being relatively new
to the political process as candidates
are still seeing as the outsiders a
little bit more beyond reproach a little
bit more ethical but that's why people
like Barbara Boxer and patty Murray now
are seen as the insiders and they're
having trouble hanging on to those seats
in very blue states because who was once
the outsider is now the insider let's
get the calls beginning with Raleigh
North Carolina this is sorry Taylor
Michigan first this is Debbie
independent line go ahead please hi I
find this really interesting and I'm
glad that you have both these young
women on the air here today I really
would like to come from the perspective
of I'm a mother I'm a young grandmother
at least I like to think so of ten
grandchildren and what I think about
when I vote and I am very independent
okay I have voted both Democrat and
Republican I vote for the person and I
vote for the person that respects
women's rights and what I'm finding I am
so proud that there are so many women
candidates running but my problem comes
in the same way I think about male
candidates running
I don't want dumb uneducated unthinking
and disrespectful candidates whether
they be male or female and what I find
running today on some of the women with
some of the women is they are and
uneducated
disrespectful towards the fight that my
generation of women fought for so that
women like you can sit there and these
women candidates can run Debbie thank
you so much well mr. mayor you suggested
that you liked the fact that there's the
full panoply of candidates out there how
would you respond to her well I think
there are few things I think it you know
debbie has a point that we that we see a
lot I mean women ultimately a lot of
people men and women will vote with
their party allegiances or with their
other kinds of views that they have and
then gender plays a role but it is not
determinative it's not the sole
determining factor in in how folks vote
I mean you have these Democratic
candidates like Barbara Boxer like patty
Murray and you have folks men running
against Republican women who have an
advantage among women they lead their
Republican woman opponent among women
for many potentially some of the reasons
that Debbie mentioned or for there are
other issues that that voters care about
and I do think that you know what Debbie
talked about in terms of her her family
background and thinking about that we
work with a Democratic candidate Cathy
doll Kemper and she is a grandmother and
talks about in her ads I'm a new
grandmother and that's you know that's
part of her profile just as Kellyanne
was saying and that's something that she
she talks about because that is
something that voters really relate to
in his part of her if you don't mind I'm
gonna take a call we'll come back and
forth between you among calls here next
is a call from Marietta California and
this is Howard a Republican go ahead
Howard good morning good morning
I would like to say to the gentleman
from Texas didn't quite get the argument
down the last in the last segment I
appreciate your patience dear ladies let
me see the last lady that called wanted
to emphasize dumb women and uneducated
women Margie
before any conversation you should have
I think you should put out there
thirteen trillion dollar deficit that
would be a good way for Democratic women
to explain what they're gonna do for
this country okay
we have in California the opportunity to
elect two very bright women and I am
voting for them and supporting them 100%
these are long lived political activists
these are women that have been very
successful in business one of the
comments about mrs. Whitman is as she
shipped 30,000 jobs overseas and not to
Burbank like but suggest and I would
suggest when Meg left her corporation
she was employing 30,000 people Howard
thank you so much I was looking at
statistics from Rutgers and just to the
point of having the choices of two women
in California there are now there are 14
different races this year Governor
Senate house that are women versus women
I think is that a record it sounds like
it might it is a record and your
previous caller before Howard from
Californian thank you sir she lives in a
state in Michigan where they do have a
female governor and a female United
States Senator so there are places where
this already exists Howard raises an
excellent insight that is very typical
of this year's voter including female
voter and that's this concern about
macroeconomics for years you know we
pollsters and other strategists have
recognized that women primarily focus on
the micro economics the household budget
the kitchen table concerns that's now
being coupled this political cycle with
a real appreciation and a knowledge a
financially sophisticated knowledge for
many voters of macroeconomics for the
first time since Gallup has been asking
the question in 10 years they ask the
question looking ahead 25 years what do
you think will be the most important
problem facing the United States for the
first time ever their federal budget
deficit was the number one issue that
just blew me away to think that men and
women in this country are not saying the
economy generally or education or
nuclear holocaust are saying the federal
budget deficit it tells you a great deal
about this election cycle when many
voters including female voters can tell
you chapter and verse about the health
care legislation in the stimulus package
they've read most of the 2,000 pages
even if their members
Congress have not Charlotte to North
Carolina Deb is up next Democrat you're
on the air good morning I'm a first-time
caller
thank you you know back in 2000 I
seriously looked at John McCain I am a
Democrat but I also look at the person
running and John McCain in 2008 was so
different from John McCain of 2000 that
there is no way I could have voted for
him and the problem that I had was that
the Republican Party put up Sarah Palin
who in my opinion was almost an insult
to women that they put the curtain up
that thought that the women would just
say all okay she wears a dress
so obviously I'm gonna vote for her I
did vote for Senator Hillary Clinton in
the primary I will vote for women in the
future but not women who don't know the
issues not women who run on a campaign
of judge negative ad negativity and so I
that's one reason I will never vote
Republican is my issues the Democrats
always have my top three issues
that's abortion environmental rights and
rights for gays and Republicans almost
never get my vote it's simply because
they do not come down on that side of
the issue that I come on okay thanks
response to her yeah I think because we
don't have that many examples of
different kinds of women candidates at
the top of the ticket or gubernatorial
Senate candidates sometimes we find
ourselves looking to happen and this is
the story that the press wants us to
sometimes have to to graft on to these
women candidate it's the story of all
women just like them so Meg Whitman and
Carly Fiorina I think people sometimes
look to them now as the sign that women
as executives don't work as candidates
and I don't think that's why they're
struggling in their racism and I think
it's you know it's a shame that that
folks have made voters
believe that sarah palin should be an
example of all women or all mother
candidates and really all these women
candidates are individuals and
individual specifics of their races and
as we have more women candidates i think
that's going to be that's going to be
less of an issue for them
well that caller is hardly a swing voter
she'll be in your party's column for a
while that she raises a very important
point and that's this and it's a good
thing which is that women don't
necessarily vote for women as a woman i
applaud that because women are looking
for someone who share their age their
ideas on issues and their values however
you define values not their gender and i
think that's a tremendous strength it's
also why you know the traditional gender
gap of men favoring Republicans and
women favoring democrats as an
overgeneralization is still true what's
exploded this year by and large is that
men prefer republicans that much more
but when she talks about very
fascinating to me the caller from
charlotte north carolina talks about her
three top issues and those three top
issues
she said abortion environment and gay
rights those are three issues where this
president has seen a lot of
disappointment among his own ranks there
has been a great deal of frustration
reported very recently particularly over
Don't Ask Don't Tell and this president
not making good on his own promises and
so I wonder how that will play out in
2012 those issues don't really play out
in 2010 so much well picking up some of
these themes I wanted to show you an
opinion piece written by Andrew yarrow
who is described as a public policy
professor historian and journal
journalist scuse me who is in this
morning's Baltimore Sun the year of the
macho woman ironically female candidates
epitomized the current Republican
Party's tough-guy image and this is
referring to Sarah Palin's mama grizzly
quote the man up comment made by Sharron
Angle to Harry Reid and he writes if one
characterizes masculinity and femininity
never before has the Republican base
been so hyper masculine and never has
the rest of the party been so browbeaten
into playing the role of wimps the
sidelines boys who cheer on the 280
pound take-no-prisoners linebacker
meanwhile the Democratic Party is seen
as comprising nearly women or as Arnold
Schwarzenegger
Eggar said of his political opponents
the girly men if masculinity is about
aggressively taking a firm stance
obliterating rather than compromising
with opponents and fighting with blind
fury then the tea party Republicans and
their johnny-come-lately acolytes in
Congress take the star roles in the 22
2010 remake of True Grit ironically many
of these most masculine of the new
Republicans are women I'm citing to
Michele Bachmann Sharron Angle Christine
O'Donnell and of course Sarah Palin we
think about this need to project a tough
person tough-guy image I guess you would
say as a female candidate I mean I can
certainly see why there's a tendency for
folks who want to do that right for
candidates and want to do that and for
folks to find that interesting I find
the man of comments and the this sort of
it's a little bit of a caricature that I
find a little bit regrettable and I
think that women candidates can be
Republican or a Democrat can be strong
and convey strength without having to
use the sort of nomenclature that I
think really emphasizes the
stereotypical differences that people
see between the genders rather than show
that women candidates can be tough
without having to use phrases like man
up I mean I just I think to me that the
tracks from the debate it makes it a
little more cartoonish and simple and
round and rather than the complexity
that we have with a lot of these women
candidates now that's what you think
when you poll do you hear anything
different from the people that you talk
to you well I think the people that we
talk to aren't always you know things
like this this man up is very you know
it was a big moment and it was a big
moment here in Washington conserver a
couple candidates used it within a day
and so I don't I'm not sure that that
ultimately is something that swing
voters who decide late who you know arm
breathlessly watching you know the
campaign's twists and turns all around
the country every campaign the way
c-span audience does I think that that's
not necessarily as a sailing incident
one of the greatest obstacles for female
candidates over the decades has been
their inability to raise money the other
obstacle for them has been to be seen as
tough enough among enough voters to
actually succeed and win these seats and
that includes tough enough among men and
women voters and this this toughness is
that much more important when the
issues our economic and our national
security slash war in nature because we
all know that when the people will say
well let the girls handle the head the
health care and even crinkle their nose
it let them do the education health care
thing talk about the environment once in
a while stick some abortion policy in
there whereas you've got to reflect what
the voters are saying which is behind
large economy and jobs so you do have to
project some kind of toughness I'm not a
huge fan of name-calling not saying that
that was but I think you can Margaret
Thatcher had a great phrase she said she
was certainly tough and certainly if she
said being powerful is like being a lady
if you have to say you are then you
probably are not so I think there's a
way to show that you're tough qualify
for the job and still not use all your
late lose your ladylike behavior but
look ladies this this recession has hit
men really hard seven and ten of the job
losses who have been absorbed by men so
you have many women who are toughening
up in their own households and in their
own lives having to carry most of or all
of the freight for the family household
until the economy picks back up but I
think that toughness is being reflected
in some of our candidates I want to come
back to this discussion after calls but
specifically talk about voter reaction
to Nancy Pelosi and that whole tough
woman versus the issues she's involved
in and perception on the voters but
looks here from Arlington Virginia David
independent good morning David all right
we're gonna move on sorry about that
let's go next to Lafayette Georgia
Sheila Republican line all right yeah
respondent the lady was talking about
dumb women bowser's that was a about
women being dumb that's running for
Sheila you're hearing your TV volume in
the background that's why it's hard when
you can't talk and listen to that delay
we hit the mute button and then go ahead
Santa Teresa okay I need to listen to Al
Franklin can you hear me now yes we can
they need to listen to Al Franklin all
right they even running now
Al Franken is not running this year
Sheila thinks we're gonna move on to a
call from Anchorage Alaska this is Tommy
Democrats line Tommy you got a big race
going on up there you know
Alaska what's your perspective going
into this weekend we have unexpected you
know miss Palin she's uh she's probably
the governor of Alaska and we up here
and she quit
you know she wanna run for president but
when he gets and bang get a little bit
tough she takes off you know it's a lot
of great woman's in this world that it's
fighters and it's just that when you a
fighter you don't just stop when things
get rough now she quit as the governor
of Alaska and we got walls and Iran and
all them kind of places when things get
tough is she gonna say okay I could well
Tommy let me ask you about your Senate
race with Lisa Murkowski coming back in
running as a write-in well you know what
though the truth is I don't understand
like nice Mycoskie number one is because
you know up here we got a lot of cooking
eruption I mean corruption and she was
mixed up in a land deal you know and our
men were loosed up and I mean like that
baggage wouldn't accept in the land deal
so it's just that that's good seem like
it's only with one of the third
countries so y'all done they don't hear
too much about what actually going on up
here
you know it's it's like we appear at
black I'm black man we are seeing black
we over you know it's just that we don't
have no voice our courts have one of the
highest conviction rate there is up here
and our governor and our senators like
mr. Don Young baseball to make sure that
all of citizens rights would be
protected but the only thing they're
doing right now is trying to get elected
ain't thinking about the citizen up here
tell me how long have you lived in
Alaska I've been Alaska since 1977 1977
I think like and what are you doing up
so early
dude how are you why are you up so early
it's
what I've been watching your show all
the time trying to get on the phone to
talk to you thanks very much what do you
do for a living
me I got injured and 0-6 and unemployed
right now I'm not working cuz I'm off
injured so well thank you for spending
some of your late night early morning
with us here on c-span Tommy from
Anchorage Alaska well there were Sarah
Palin comments and also Senate comments
and I'll let you pick it up and respond
to anything they would interested you
well the you know what Tom you mentioned
well there are few things one we now
know lots about what's going on in
Alaska I mean a few years ago we did not
follow all the twists and turns of
Alaska politics nationally the way we
are now so now I think the country is
very familiar with the political
landscape in Alaska but it's interesting
talking about governor Palin quitting
and Karl Rove said the same thing a few
days ago that about her reality show and
saying I don't really want to be in a
stuffy office is not a good preview to a
presidential run and so I think Tommy
and Karl Rove made me have a lot in
common
well when Sarah Palin left the
governorship obviously people had
varying opinions as to why that was and
whether it was appropriate that being I
guess a very personal decision but it
seems she thought she can make a bigger
impact on politics and on the national
landscape and I think nobody can argue
that that indeed was true she has sort
of gone and waved her magic wand
endorsed people and they've won their
primaries so by and large this cycle so
she is an important voice I actually
think all voices are important because
that's democracy this whole matter of
who will run for president in 2012 I
think is premature particularly either
the midterm elections and there are
always surprises there always people who
folks believe absolutely will positively
run and win and they end up not running
and then there are always some dark
horses and some light dark horses maybe
oh yes I thought that person might get
into the race but now they definitely
will so she's gonna have an impact on
politics I think he'd be hard pressed to
find a political figure who brings out
more emotion and passion in people on
both sides of the passion spectrum and
again I think that's healthy for
democracy and I
believe that the runs for president and
vice-president of Senator Clinton and
governor Palin in 2008 ended up having a
positive effect on women wanting to run
for office women traditionally don't
want to run for office their
congenitally hardwired against it it
takes too much time away from the things
they love they they're not part of the
old boys or the new boys Network how do
I break in is so rough-and-tumble you
have to have the fire in your belly but
you also have to file in your throat
because the way candidates are treated
now and the ads and and the ubiquitous
slights against candidates but I think
that they have both Clinton and Palin
have had a positive effect on women
wanting to go beyond the ballot box as a
way to participate and actually run for
office well I said earlier I wanted to
talk about Nancy Pelosi let me broaden
the question out and ask about Nancy
Pelosi and John Boehner both and the
Republicans are just about a month ago
through mr. Boehner attempted to
nationalize the congressional elections
by putting out their pledge and also
with many appearances by mr. Boehner
who's now become quieter Nancy Pelosi
has been less visible will you talk
about the leadership in Congress and how
much it might or might not affect
people's and decisions on local
elections well there are a few things so
first when they rolled out the pledge
and John Boehner said we're going to be
exactly how we've been that was sort of
the beginning and an end of John Boehner
sore visible national role and I think
that was seen as a good as a good thing
for him to say I was actually played
into what people think about the
Republicans currently um but in terms of
Nancy Pelosi I you know speaker Pelosi I
think there's no question that she that
has been a great thing for women and for
women candidates and I do think that if
she was a man you know that I'm past
male speakers have not had to face some
of the kind of personal characters that
she has I mean calling her a witch I
mean that's a gendered you know that as
her opponents done and as other people
have done in Webb viral videos and that
sort of thing I think that's a very
gendered way to talk about her and it's
not something that you can find a
comparable with a comfortable example
for certainly not for for Boehner who is
not
ticularly well-known but even for past
male speakers there was not something
similar for former speaker Hastert for
example but let me a specifically asked
on Nancy Pelosi who has been a pretty
reliable lightning rod for a number of
congressional candidates this year I
wonder when you pull people is the
reaction to her gender-based or policy
based policy based and the way we know
that is because she was the first she is
the first female Speaker of the House
that really didn't pay great political
dividends for Democrats and she's not a
very popular figure out on the campaign
trail she's not in demand you don't see
people lining up and asking her to come
and campaign for them a lot of that is
because she's seen as hyper partisan she
started out of somebody who when you ask
people do you approve or disapprove
Nancy Pelosi's job as Speaker the house
or are you favorable unfavorable the
number one response for a couple of
years was I don't know or I'm unfamiliar
with her she now is clearly in negative
territory when it comes to her
favorability ratings that is being writ
large now with calls from candidates for
office and sitting incumbent Democrats
who have said that they won't vote for
her for Speaker you just had Heath
Shuler down in North Carolina who voted
against the health care plan so probably
is safer than most who voted for it say
that he'll vote for himself over Nancy
Pelosi
that's gratuitous but it's also
strategic a couple days before the
election she ends up being you know more
of the congresswoman from San Francisco
than she is the Speaker of the House
she's hyper partisan she's helped push
the Obama agenda through but that's an
agenda that's very unpopular and that's
gonna say something well I said you know
being a leader in the legislature being
a speaker or being a Senate Majority
Leader is never a particularly national
popular position I mean people don't get
warm fuzzy feelings over Mitch McConnell
particularly he's not in demand to go
you know meet voters for for Senate
candidate so I think you know so I think
there's something about I mean if
there's something particular about Nancy
Pelosi that I think has been unfair it's
not you know she has seen as partisan
because that's how she's been character
and that's how people talked about her
it's not that she's out there you know
specifically I mean in my view and then
you know this is my view that her
statements are not as far to the left as
people imagined
that they are she's from San Francisco
and people have an imagination of what a
member of Congress from San Francisco is
like but I think that's really it has
less to do with something particularly
that she said or done and more about the
job attitudes towards Democrats and have
the character of her Greenville South
Carolina this is Bob of next Republican
go ahead I've got two quick comments one
comment one a question for your
Democratic pollster but there are 35
million people in California yet they
keep reelecting the same two senators
over and over and over
why don't they pick one of the person
out of the 35 million people to give it
a try give it a go and to give a new
voice I don't understand why they have
to keep electing the same people to
where we ended up with Barbara Boxer who
made those comments to a general of all
people that that she deserves some
respect and if you recall the comment in
to the Democratic pollster you know the
the in 2003 and for the Republicans had
strong majorities and they blew it they
really blew it and they allowed the
Democrats to get in and now the
Democrats got into the elected Pelosi as
the Speaker of the House and if you
don't know it she's a very polarizing
person how the Democrats and I'd like to
ask you is how did the Democrats
capitulate and a lot of those far left
to run their party to the point where
they had such far left people on every
post dominating thing and don't you
think that's the reason why your party
is in trouble right now
electoral II I mean it's just as simple
as the far far left is running your
party and you've gone to the point where
they just keep this going you're gonna
let illegal aliens come in here and give
them the right to vote so they can vote
primarily Democratic and it's like
you're just stuck on this to try and win
Wow thank you for your call as a mare oh
yeah I I think that the number one
reason that this is going to be a
difficult year for Democrats is because
the economy is still struggling I mean
that that's clearly the prevailing
concern I don't think any one member of
Congress is really part of what the
National the National prevailing mood I
think it really is a lot of you know
people are still struggling and they
want to see they want to see a recovery
speed up a little bit in terms of the
senators from California I mean they you
know they're in the you know senator
boxer is in a tough race but she seems
to be pulling it out
she seems to be ahead and according to
public polls and in terms of you know
and she's had she's facing tough
challenges before and and wit and wins
with a majority of the voters so I think
that you know this is why people are
feeling more active this year they you
have you know a lot more attention on
these races but ultimately I think the
national mood and how people feel about
Democrats is really more about the
economy than about any one member of
Congress or senator when you look at
polls every pollster at this point seems
to be conceding a Republican ascendancy
in the House of Representatives but when
you look at the polls that also suggests
restive voters and the Republicans may
come in to the majority with pretty low
approval ratings overall what does what
message are voters sending to Republican
candidates even as they might decide to
give them a majority in the house
probably that you have one maybe one
point five shots at this we're not going
to that voters are not going to
countenance a repeat of a runaway
spending that they saw in the mid-2000s
in 2006 the Democrats won control of the
House and Senate in my view because a
Republicans started to act like
Democrats they expanded entitlements
they had this runaway spending and what
happened is that many of the
conservative voters stayed home I call
them conscientious objectors they opted
out of the process not because they
don't pay attention to politics but
precisely because they do you know the
Tea Party movement is really an out
shoot of frustration with spending
during the Bush years and the Obama
years they didn't just find religion on
spending because you have a Democratic
president these are people who were
against the bridge to nowhere Medicare
Part D No Child Left Behind you know
again they can tick off chapter verse to
you of republican-led and democratic-led
policies that have have rankled them
that's what they're saying I think the
Iron Age is - we've to go these two
comments the irony of this election is
that I think that the Democrats who will
be left in the Congress are going to be
more your base more liberal than
conservative these Blue Dog Democrats
really imperils going into Tuesday and
these Blue Dog Democrats of course as
your viewers can appreciate are they
fiscally conservative but they've had to
go home to the fiscally conservative
districts and defend votes on the
stimulus which hasn't worked health care
which is a trillion plus and a majority
voters are rejecting cap-and-trade and
these Blue Dogs who went along with
Nancy Pelosi and Senator Obama neither
of whom the President Obama neither of
whom is going to lose this year their
respective seats they went along with
them and they're paying the political
price and you're going to end up with
less concern or conservative Republican
majority but a less conservative
Democrat minority we have about six or
seven minutes left with our two guests
and we're talking about a campaign 2010
and women next calls from Pittsburgh
this is Jackie on the independent line
good morning Jackie
good morning hey you know I watched
politics a lot and it really amazes me
is people are not asking about an audit
of every government organization I mean
everything up there should be up for an
audit I'm sure there's a lot of
duplicity inefficiency is unknown I mean
I have kids and two of them need help
and we don't have a lot of money but
we're trying to help them I know a lot
of people unemployed from what Obama and
Democrats have done is it made it harder
for business to do business I mean and
this health care bill when I saw mr.
Baucus say or Senator Baucus say that he
didn't read the bill because he didn't
think he wanted his constituents to wait
you know waste his time because they
didn't understand it and they're voting
on these things what we really need is
bills the people understand
jaci cleaner to move from your positions
to your put your political choice on
Tuesday you've described yourself as an
independent calling in have you in fact
voted for Democrats in the past I have
exactly I live in Pennsylvania now I
moved back and forth to different states
I like mr. Casey old mr. Casey young mr.
Casey I don't care for I voted for him
and you're going to do in the Senate
race I'm gonna vote for to me we really
need somebody has got to take
accountability for the money they're
spending I mean public unions is another
one of my Bugaboo
I'm really really upset with public
unions every time I hear an ad that's
put on by a public union it's using my
taxpayer dollars to you know they're
they're trying to support a candidate
that I do not and and just not the
Democrats it's the Republicans to I saw
Bainer I'm not crazy about him I'm a
real Paul Ryan fan this young guy has
some good ideas this is the type of guy
that should be running the Republican
Party people are tired of the same old
elitist Poehler the DAO do-gooders up
there that are trying to tell me how to
live my life Jackie thank you so much
there's something in there for both of
you it's an independent the kind of
voter that either one of your parties
needs to attract why don't we start with
Kellyanne and then we'll come to us yes
this whole matter of public unions I
think that and you see all the
institution approval polling that public
unions have really fallen out of a steam
needs to be the American voter and I
think a lot of it is because they see
what people like Governor Chris Christie
are doing in New Jersey where they're
basically she's basically challenging
the teachers unions to take a pay freeze
not even lose your job but take a pray
for pay freeze and they're saying no so
the question is do you care more about
the children or your your jaw or your
your pay increase this year Bell
California these people are now going to
jail which is a good thing for really
you know violating the public trust and
raping the public coffers to fund their
salaries and pensions when she said that
she she's incensed - and she sees a
public union running ads this is a
really critical point because for all
the talk about who's funding this
election and with what money asked me
has 1.6 million members they've spent
100 million dollars and they're just
tapping into it's been reported a 16
million dollar emergency fund they're
giving all their money to Democrats and
I wonder if in a place like Nevada where
there's 15% unemployment where you have
a heavily unionized States because of
the gaming industry I wonder if those
dues-paying union members who are out of
work thought that the emergency fund was
meant to go for political purposes and
because of of outlets like c-span people
now understand that this this idea that
a public member of a public union is
just a a benevolent beneficent neighbor
next door who's giving up much more
money they can have in the
sector many people are looking at this
use of public dues mile of Union money
very wrongly for political purposes I
personally think if you pay into a union
you ought to be able to opt out of it
being used for political purposes aren't
you America well there are a couple
things so first you know when you see
those ads that say ask me at least you
know who is paying for the ad which is
different than the the overwhelming
amount of these outside groups two to
one
our Republican leading groups the
Democratic leaning groups in you can
have no idea who's behind them there you
don't need to disclose the donors and I
think that's really particularly
troubling as new this year and it's
particularly troubling for our democracy
that's the first piece now the second
piece which i think is as important as
this accountability thing and that is a
big theme in selection a lot of people
are looking for and it's actually big in
a lot of local legislative and state
level elections where people are asking
for more accountability of their state
government we work on a race for someone
for running for state Senate in Oregon
his name is Chuck Riley and he had a
bill that made national news that every
government document should be written in
plain language and it was something you
know it's incredibly popular that people
really responsive for all the same
reasons that the caller just mentioned
last calls from Brooklyn and this is
John Republican hello good morning John
good morning very thank you very much
for Sixpence
I would like to say that the the female
politician is nothing but the carbon
copy of the male politician they both
express themselves exactly like and they
both fit exactly alike and they both
dressed exactly alike so I see no
difference in this holography that we
live in we all right let's go we're
almost out of time here is the goal to
have women and and male candidates look
it sounds exactly the same where should
women bring something different to the
table I think the goal would be for
women candidates to feel free to dress
how they want present themselves how
they want in a way that's really true to
them and not feel they have to be
and copy of men unless they want to be a
carbon copy of men so I think that's
really the goal that's right and I look
back 10 years ago to when then First
Lady Hillary Clinton ran for the United
States Senate in New York a biet
successfully but she put herself in what
I described as a campaign uniform and I
see many female candidates sort of
adopting that modus operandi where she
was unfairly excoriated this first lady
for the wearing this pink suit aware
changing her hair constantly again you
never read these stories about men and
what she did was she put herself in a
campaign uniform she always had on a
navy or black pantsuit occasionally a
chocolate brown one if she was feeling
really crazy sheet ice was sort of round
and that never changed her hair and
basically subscribed to that during her
now-famous you know pantsuit writ and
presidential run and my view is that so
she couldn't she and other candidates
try to get back some of those column
inches of coverage that two paragraphs
won't be spent on whether the color of
your hair and match the color of your
bag and shoes versus you know not how
you looked and what you were but what
you said and I don't like to call it a
double standard I don't like to call it
is what it is we all are visual
creatures we do gravitate towards
someone and try to focus on them based
on remember them based on what they look
like or what they're wearing but
eventually I think voters dismiss all of
that and listen to what someone is
saying engaged voters anyway look
politics is not reality TV people aren't
auditioning to dance or sing and this is
serious stuff and I have faith in the
average voter to actually focus not on
what what people are wearing but when
what they're saying well in a year when
there's been record record numbers of
female candidates for House Senate and
governor's race and when there a record
number of two candidates male to female
candidates going head to head in races
we're very pleased to have our two
guests here Kelly Ann Conway and Margie
Romero to talk to us about women
candidates and women voters in these
days leading up to the election thank
you to both of the